when you think of the union of soviet
socialist republics you probably don't
think of millionaires the soviet union
was
after all a communist country built upon
the ideals of economic equality
that said human beings like to do their
own thing and getting rich in a country
that you're not supposed to is hardly
unimaginable
so did it ever happen were there any
millionaires in the ussr and if so how
did the people there react
so there are some difficulties in
answering this question since there were
limitations on how money in the soviet
union worked
for example quantities of cars toilet
paper and foods were strictly controlled
and so getting more of these was reliant
on political connections not cash
and also it's not like you could be so
rich that you could retire early since
for most lengthy unemployment was
against the law
that said if you had the political
connections and the right job you could
live a pretty comfortable life
comparable to millionaires in the west
for example many high-ranking ministers
who served under stalin had very little
concept of money
since as government ministers they could
ask for something and simply be brought
it with no money leaving their pockets
one funny anecdote which demonstrates
this is from when stalin and his
ministers were going for a walk around
moscow
and doing so they saw an old lady
struggling to cross the road
stalin helped her to cross and then
wanted to give her some money to help
her out
one problem though neither stalin nor
his ministers carried any money with
them since they never used it and the
old lady got squat
anyway to answer the question as to
whether or not there were any people who
had the equivalent of a million dollars
openly in the ussr the answer was yes
although it didn't happen until very
late in its life after gorbachev had
reformed the economy to allow some
private enterprise some people started
to make a lot of money
particularly from importing luxury goods
from the west and one man who did this
was artium tarazov who in 1989 declared
on television that he was the first
person in the ussr to be worth millions
of rubles
which wasn't millions in terms of us
dollars but given that for most soviet
citizens their yearly wage was between
1500 and 3
000 rubles it was a lot so how did the
soviet people react
well very well in the all congratulated
tarazovon just kidding they were
outraged
protests sprang up in major cities
politicians denounced the acquisition of
capital on that scale and many called
for tarazov to be imprisoned
his accounts were frozen and the kgb
launched an investigation into him but
ultimately they found nothing and so he
was allowed to go back to his business
and soon after he became a millionaire
in the traditional sense
now not a lot is known about tarazov in
his business but what is certain is that
his relations with the soviet government
were pretty awful and it wasn't long
until he fled the country and eventually
settled in the uk
despite all of this hubbub though more
and more soviet citizens became
wealthier and wealthier over the next
two years
and when the ussr collapsed and many
public assets were sold off it was these
people mostly who brought shares in them
and whose wealth then subsequently
exploded
giving some of the post-soviet states
the oligarchs that they're known for
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bisonette kelly money maker marvin
cassell moe rob waterhouse james
castaneda jerry lamdin gustav swan aaron
the whites jordan longley marcus asner
charles the first rasheed ali coppertone
maggie paxkowski lexi schwinn miss is it
matthew shipley robert wetzel spinning
three plates spencer lightfoot
corso wolfe anthony beckett and winston
caywood